hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video you know
today's uh Wednesday January 4th 2023
it is the day that they released the FED
minutes and we're gonna get into some of
the interesting order flow that was
there uh today in the e-minis you know I
mean anytime you have a Fed announcement
or minutes coming out or you know CPI
non-front payrolls you know it's always
interesting to take a look at what what
was taking place at the market sort of
leading up into it and you know
afterwards but before we begin you know
be sure to like and like the channels
subscribe to the channel and more
importantly you know like the videos you
know because that's what helps us get
found in the algo and you know sort of
keeps gives me the motivation to keep
making more videos for you
um so you know coming into the day's
cash session we had a pretty tight range
you know for S PS considering you know
um 3870 was a high basically 38 40 was
the low I mean the low was actually 39
and a quarter but you know more or less
about a 30 point range and you know for
the S PS nowadays that that is
considered a tight range and then once
cash opened up you know we sort of
tested the highs pulled back a little
bit and started making new highs we came
off some more but then we started making
new highs again going into you know
around
um you know what time was that just
around 10 30 or so started making these
new Highs but what I want to talk about
is that high that we had made up here at
uh 10 you know 10 58 to about you know
11 for about an hour before we started
selling off but what I'm going to do is
I want to take a look at the cumulative
Delta okay so let's just go back here
and so this was our high at 10 58 right
we had hit that high 96 and a quarter
Delta was at a high as well and then
what happens is we pull back a little
bit I don't want to say we sold off but
you know we just had this little bit of
a pullback and sort of went sideways
and then we started making a run back up
towards the high of the day again six
and a quarter I think we got as high as
like four or five or 95 I think it was
um
but what was happening is Delta started
making another run and we broke out and
started making new highs in the
cumulative Delta right the Delta for the
day
however price wasn't making new highs
right so bear that in mind right when
you're making new highs
you expect to see Delta make in new
highs
and if it's not that should get your
yours pointing up and say you know your
radar going through you know something's
going on here because remember right we
got the fomc minutes coming out
here at one o'clock
all right so if you know the the day
Traders
um you know the prop guys the internet
Traders they don't want to hold their
position through the fomc minutes I mean
you know even though the FED has sort of
been hinting that
um you know they're not going to do any
Cuts you know for the next year you know
when you see the actual statement that
says yeah you know we're we're doing a
great job you know and start patting
themselves on the back that uh you know
they're still staying hawkish
um
yeah I don't know it's just one of those
things where it's you know these fed
minutes it's more of a you know
congratulatory thing on on to themselves
so yeah we're doing a great job with the
economy look at this look at that
um you know you don't really expect to
see any major changes you know they're
not going to stick a line in there it
says oh yeah we're gonna we're gonna do
this but nevertheless the point being
you're an hour away from the release of
the minutes okay so if you're a day
trader you want to sort of be squaring
up your position ahead of time and if
this Market had just made a new high at
10 58
and an hour later
more or less we're coming back up
towards the high and can't take it out
even though the aggressive buying is
there what is that telling you you so
think about us break it down you have
aggressive buying taking place okay you
expect the market to go up
but it's not well what's happening on
the other side of the trade well you
probably have
absorption taking place or in this case
honestly absorption because they'll
confuse some people you should have is
distribution you have Supply coming into
the market basically absorbing all that
aggressive buying you have Traders up at
these levels up here that are happy to
sell it
to the you know everybody that's coming
in right now looking to get long
because
if you have Supply remember right if you
have Supply to sell the easiest way to
sell it is into a rising market
right not once the market starts
dropping because once the market starts
dropping everybody's looking to sell but
if the market is sort of going up
that's the easiest time to sell a
position
not when it's dropping when it's
dropping you end up chasing price now
let's take a look at
what the order flow was because what
happened was you know we made that new
high in the cumulative Delta but price
didn't make the new high then you start
seeing signs and weakness
um you know the big
red cumulative Delta candles right the
big Delta candles with the strong
negative Delta and price dropped s PS
dropped from you know more or less the
the 93 area down to you know the mid 70s
so almost a 20 point drop and this drop
happened very quickly it happened in
about you know 10 or 15 minutes
so let's take a look at the order flow
chart so this was the high right the
high at 10.58 over there at 96 and a
quarter as I said we pulled back a
little bit and more or less just went
sideways
um work started to get interesting is
here right so again this green line here
is the high of the day and
we got up to what 95 so we got within a
point and a quarter
and you know before here you're seeing
the positive Deltas in each bar nothing
you know
it's really big I mean you see some bars
with some selling coming in here minus
300 minus 100
um but this bar here was very telling
okay because for a number of reasons one
obviously it's got a big strong negative
Delta minus
822 contracts it's closing near its Min
Delta number of minus 826 and it's got a
very strong Delta
divided by volume number of minus 28 so
that's why it's colored this magenta
sort of a darker color that's what our
software does is it will highlight to
you the trader that hey you know what
you've got very strong selling taking
place right now in the market I mean
obviously it's you got this Bar's got
one two three four five six selling
imbalances obviously it's a bit of a
bigger bar than some of these others but
nevertheless you know all signs are
pointing that hey you know what there's
some strong selling taking place here
and again you got to start to put the
pieces of the puzzle together saying
okay we're at the high we couldn't take
it up we got fed minutes coming out in
an hour you know
intraday traders that were buying it in
here are on this way up you know they're
still trying to buy it see if they could
take it out they're not so now what you
have is all these people that were
buying it in here
are turning sellers right they're
starting it to take place here at this
you know bar between
um you know 93 and a half and 91. okay
back here on the on the footprint and
look at the volume it's 2800 28.98 it's
almost 3 000 contracts the previous big
volumes you know here is 2300 here's
2600 there's a 2700 but you don't have
these strong volumes like that right so
the volume is is
sort of the strongest it's been
in almost an hour I don't say in an hour
because here's you know 3 800 it's 3 900
at the high yeah you had 4 000 yeah at
10.58 and this high is taking or sorry
rather this bar is at 11 40. So within
an hour right it's one of the highest
volumes definitely in the last 30
minutes
okay then it just sort of goes inside
before you get another big flush right
here 38 you know from the 91 and a
quarter down to 88 and uh you know 80s
you know basically 88 so you got two
bars very strong
negative Delta very strong Delta volume
right because you know the 923 the final
Delta is very close to its Min Delta of
minus 948 so you know this bar is
closing at almost its strongest Min
Delta number right Min Delta is how
strong
the negative Delta was in a bar for
closing sort of on it you know it's just
telling you this it's kind of
overwhelming in that case then the 923
you know the bars traded 3329 contracts
923 that number the Delta number divided
into 3329 is minus 27.
percent
so I mean normally you're going to see
the
Delta divided by volume it's going to be
a smaller number you know five percent
six percent ten percent but when you
start getting above certain levels
that's why we color the magenta because
those we found stand out because those
are just it's just something to tell
anything that's going to give you a hint
before a move starts and in this case
it's a move down because we're seeing
the strong selling you want to be
alerted to that as early as possible
because it started here okay maybe you
know you might not have been convinced
it'll say well it's just one bar maybe
I'm not convinced yet right but then you
get a couple minutes later another very
similar bar right the strong negative
Delta
the strong Delta divided by volume so
you got two bars within basically you
know four minutes here but basically on
the other end of two minutes
what do you think the trade is right
because you know got people dumping
their position and again you're
up here right you made a run back up
towards the high of the day and now it's
starting to break down you're seeing the
Delta cumulative Delta if you're
watching the Delta chart you saw Delta
making new highs price not making new
highs that's an important piece of
information now you're starting to see
you know the aggressive sellers coming
in here right you know just killing all
these bids so you know that this
reversal is probably starting so even if
you're getting you know I'm not saying
that you would have gotten short
necessarily off this Divergence and
cumulative Delta you'd want to look for
some signs in the order flow you start
seeing it here in this bar at 11 49 and
then again you know ah you know what
you know I'm not convinced yet by the
time this bar comes in you should be
convinced there's still plenty of time
to be getting short around you know the
88 89 I don't say 90. I don't think it
got up to 90 I think it got like 89 and
three quarters but you got plenty of you
got one two three minutes to get short
before more selling came in and it
dropped from you know 88
down to 78 over the next you know seven
minutes that's a quick 10 point move
then you then you're out you don't have
to worry about what's going to happen
here
when the you know when the minutes are
released
right and basically what the way I look
at it is you know everybody that was
buying this Market looking for it to go
higher once they realize this Market
isn't going higher that's when they
became sellers because again if you're
an intraday Trader you're not gonna hold
it through the fomc minutes that's the
time you go you know you have your
coffee you go start making your coffee
and you sit and you see what's going to
happen in the order flow right if you're
an intraday Trader you're going to be
kind of whacked on in my opinion I mean
the trade during
a minute release I mean that that's just
you know sort of what I was taught
many many years ago right the only
people that are busy trading during the
fomc minutes or announcements are the
the retail traders that are covering
their ass so you know the fomc came out
right and you can see it
knee jerk down Spike up back down again
and you know just give you a point of
reference right the high of this bar at
one o'clock 91 and a quarter will call
it 90 down here
74 and a quarter
um you know 743 quarters but you know
what we'll call it 75 75 to
you know when I call it 91.
75 to 91 I can't do the math right now
16 points 16 points in that one minute
right
keep in mind right we came into the day
that's what I was talking about you know
understanding how quiet it was overnight
we had a 30 point range So within one
bar we did half of the day's range
in that one bar when the iPhone C came
out okay and obviously you got some
other bars that are they're just as big
right and you know even some of these
bars this one was uh 69 basically down
to
um 54 so again about a 15 Point bar
but again there's obviously if you're
trading
[Music]
um
you know a one minute chart during fomc
you probably want to change your chart
setting to probably a 30 second chart to
to manage it a bit more because honestly
once that volatility picks up
based off the minutes release then
this information gets old really quick
right if you're trading
um you know like these imbalances in
here right you want to be trading them
as soon as they're
printed and seem to be holding
so you know that's what I do and I just
go to a shorter chart it's a little bit
more manageable for me in terms of
analyzing the order flow when a Market's
moving a little bit quack quick quacker
quicker
because that allows me to react sooner
on the information that's coming because
you know for me I like to wait for the
bar to close and if the market
volatility is picked up quite a bit you
know almost doubled in in the terms of
you know way price is moving
um
you know going to a shorter time frame
or something that is going to allow me
to analyze what's happening in the order
flow uh quicker
is for me
um a lot easier to to manage the order
flow so anyway guys I hope you guys
found this video a bit helpful right
again you know watch for those
cumulative Delta divergences
um yeah you don't see them every day
honestly but uh you know I thought that
with that Delta diverge cumulative Delta
Divergence
cut taking place ahead of the fomc
meeting
um you know it's set up you know a nice
trade opportunity sorry about everyone
again if you like this video be sure to
hit the like button and if you haven't
yet subscribe to the channel I'll see
you guys on the next video bye-bye